most Democrats do not want Joe Biden to
run again so should he and don't want to
run versus wouldn't vote for him are two
completely different things I have said
before I would rather someone other than
Joe Biden in fact Joe Biden was not
really my first choice in 2020 either
but at the end of the day the options
were Trump and Biden and Biden was the
better choice I think there's no
question that there is a clamoring among
many on the left for someone other than
Joe Biden probably someone younger it
shouldn't be offensive to say that it
does seem to be what the electorate
wants but I do believe if it came down
to Biden versus DeSantis or Trump I
think just about everybody on the left
still votes Biden agree disagree let me
know in the comments